boston children's hospital
is just
putting its foot right on the
accelerator of our one-way trip to
gomorrah
they are now offering
gender-affirming hysterectomies for
young girls
the slippery slope has gone we're in
warp speed on the slippery slope
it went from
we had a society where we understood
that men and women are different
to a society where men and women
kind of seen as interchangeable you know
feminism came around a woman needs a man
like fish needs a bicycle then to a
society especially you see this in the
gay rights movement where men and
women's roles including in
romantic partnerships are totally
blurred and a man can be a woman and a
woman can be a man and then this was
taken to its fullest extreme through
transgenderism where they said no a
woman literally can be a man and a man
literally can be a woman and then then
we said actually if that's true then it
can't just be true for adults it's got
to be true for kids because you know
you're born this way and you've you
you've got the soul of a woman in the
body of a man from the moment that
you're conceived even though you're not
really a person when you're conceived
you're only a person when the feminists
want to admit that a baby's become a
baby but that's actually a side point i
digress we have to trans the children
it's very important we're going to bring
transgenderism down to even elementary
school and we're going to at least at
the very least put them on totally
reversible
uh totally reversible puberty blockers
and those totally reversible cross-sex
hormones even though all of these drugs
that then get you on the hook to big
pharma for life at a huge expense huge
profits for big pharma even though they
cause all sorts of problems and you're
beginning to see this osteoporosis
sometimes permanent sterility in kids
that's no big deal don't worry it's
totally reversible oh yeah and now also
we're going to surgically remove the
wombs of children
to accommodate this absurd
fad this cult called transgenderism
so says
boston
children's
hospital
here's the advertisement gender firming
hysterectomy is very similar to most
hysterectomies that occur
hysterectomy itself is the removal of
the uterus the cervix which is the
opening of the uterus and the fallopian
tubes which are attached to the sides of
the uterus some gender affirming
hysterectomies will also include the
removal of the ovaries but that's
technically a separate procedure called
a bilateral oophectomy and not every
gender forming hysterectomy includes
that and people who are getting gender
forming hysterectomies do not have to
have their ovaries removed
smiley smiley yeah so um what we're
gonna do is not everyone has to have
their ovaries removed okay you know
you've noticed this how liberal usually
white millennial women they end every
question or every sentence rather as
though it were a question and it always
kind of ends up and it's on a lilt and
it's really nice it sounds nice but you
can tell there's a tension there because
what they're talking about is totally
insane and really really scary and
vaguely threatening so we're gonna
remove your fallopian tubes and maybe
take out your ovaries
but at the very least little kids we're
gonna remove your womb
you expect when you see this kind of
evil in the country you expect it to
come with a pitchfork and horns
and maybe a kind of
scary demonic voice
listen kids we're going to cut your womb
out ah but but that's not how it happens
actually it's even more insidious than
that it happens in the name of
compassion and being really nice you
know and being really polite and that's
why little girls we're going to chop
your womb out
because you mistakenly think you're a
boy and we're going to affirm you in
that delusion and then you're going to
regret it later on and we're going to
have destroyed your body in your life
obviously this should be shut down
anyone who is donating any money to this
hospital should stop on look i'm sure
the hospital does great work otherwise
they need to
put massive pressure cultural and social
pressure to shut down this clinic which
is really performing true evil on little
kids and then we need political pressure
to shut this down from the level of the
city in the state needs to be banned the
people who who perform these kinds of
surgeries
should be in prison
certainly
maybe
maybe you have a kind of amnesty right
now and you say okay people who were uh
wrongly doing this you didn't understand
it it was legal okay so we're not going
to throw you in the gulags yet but
now we've passed this law if anyone even
so much as thinks about performing the
surgery afterward you're going to prison
we're throwing away the key we're going
to treat you so viciously in prison it
will be as though you danced around the
capitol rotunda in a horn head on
january 6th that's how harsh we're going
to be to you for chopping out the wombs
of little girls you freaking psychos
it's everywhere this ideology is
everywhere in society now it's not just
on the extreme crazy fringes of the
capitol hill autonomous zone in some
bizarre left-wing city with a bunch of
anarchists and misfits and miscreants
running the show this is happening in
our elite institutions boston children's
hospital is a prestigious institution
it's happening right here in my own town
i love nashville nashville's so great
i've been in nashvillia now for two
years or something love tennessee
and you can even see it creeping in here
i fled liberal california
to be in a normal place
and yet here
you've got
the elite girls school harpeth hall
just announced even the elite school in
tennessee
is going trans
harpeth hall dates back to 1865.
it's an all girls school i don't have
any daughters yet i hope at some point
to have daughters i am i think i might
be too virile i just keep producing men
i am just so filled to the brim with y
chromosomes and and just brute
masculinity that i keep producing boys
but at some point i'm i may have a girl
and i hope i do so that i can grant
people favors on her wedding day if i
have a girl someday if i am so blessed i
cannot send her to harvard hall i can't
do it
because harper hall has just gone trans
because harper hall which was the girls
school in tennessee
is no longer a girls school even though
they're pretending to be a girls school
orbithal produced reese witherspoon
amy grant minnie pearl lots of famous
alumnae not alumni alumni would would
imply just boys or boys and girls but
it's alumnae because it's just girls but
now they don't produce alumnae they
produce
alumni
the website
of the school says people need to live
honorably and think critically
until transgenderism i guess and then
you throw a critical thought out the
window the school's board of trustees
diversity equity and inclusion committee
has just created this new policy at the
request of the school's administration
the policy claims that trustees quote
have heard from experts on the topic
shared educational articles and
consulted with other girls schools so
here's how i know i couldn't send my
daughter to harpett hall someday in
nashville because
they they don't know anything about
anything they say they've consulted
experts
but you don't need an expert to know
boys and girls are different you don't
need to be an expert to know that boys
can't become little girls and girls
can't become little boys so if the
school at the very highest levels is so
confused on this that they don't know
the difference between boys and girls
then i can't trust them to teach my
daughter anything because they don't
know anything they are demonstrating
such a degree of ignorance and idiocy
maybe willful ignorance i suspect it is
that i couldn't i couldn't trust them to
teach my kids the abcs
the policy quote any
student who identifies as a girl may
apply to our school so they give in to
the fad
and it's not going to turn out well i
mentioned this this quote yesterday on
the show i don't know if it's from
fulton sheen or dean inge i don't know
something i think the catholics and the
protestants fight over who gets to claim
this quote it's a brilliant quote i love
it whoever said it
whoever
marries himself to the spirit of the age
will find himself a widower in the next
if you marry yourself to the spirit of
the age you will become a widow in the
next because the spirit of the age is
always changing and that's why you've
got to ground yourself in eternal truths
not in passing fads and transgenderism
is a passing fad that's not even a
prediction that's just an historical
fact transgenderism has cropped up at
various times throughout history in
different forms and different kinds of
transgender expressions i guess you
could say but it's come up as the
gnostic dualist heresy it's come up in a
way as albigensianism catherism
it's come up
in in various forms and now it's coming
up in this particular transgender way
i'm glad you like that clip now we've
hit a million subscribers that's great
we we've got to hit a billion okay i
think that's the logical next step
i don't know what what kind of trophy
you get for a billion subscribers when
you hit a million you get a gold trophy
i assume you'll get i don't know
kryptonite or something and a billion i
really want to hit it so subscribe like
ring the bell we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]